all right and we are live how you doing
everybody and welcome to round table
with the stream team and this is where
we talk to amazing content creators and
their journeys on becoming what they are
today
and tonight we are sitting at the round
table with our friend Bob Dunn Bob how
are you doing I'm doing great thanks for
having me thank you very much for
joining us I know that we kind of had a
little ping pong of a schedule and you
know 100% my fault and I apologize but
as people can hear probably my voice is
a little crackling a little I'm a little
under the weather but I need to make
sure I got those meds in for PAX East so
yes I wanted to want to make sure that
we did an interview proper for Bob so uh
so thanks again for for letting us
reschedule this week no worries
and we have two other panelists here
today good friends of you know the
stream team as I should say MJ is a boss
well Bob how you doing it's kind of hard
but I'm making it yeah yeah just kind of
make sure the sleep schedules are all
good sure make sure you're not drinking
too much a lot of Pedialyte all right
and we also have our lovely lady how are
you how are you good I'm pretty good
first I just killed a few people yeah
well I like literally got there at 9:00
so yeah and I don't yeah I don't know
what's going on with a rink but for
whatever reason I'm having a tough time
the rink so I went back to Wrigley Field
people did about myself basically
are you are you ready with your over the
same choose one for the most part I run
with like Fozzie and stitch um I don't
know we just been making it work so any
game like that work yeah two people
three people that are gonna constantly
play together it's it makes all the
difference I mean if you're really
trying to like move up and rank yeah
like I like I'm totally down to like
play with viewers if they want to play
but I'm not playing right I know a lot
of people who end up having two accounts
one account is for people you actually
care about your ranks with you know this
sounds a little sweaty so I don't think
why do you do that I have two accounts
for tarkov one account I when I play is
like my main account that I put my main
crew with and then the other account is
the one where I play with people that I
know are gonna like shoot me in the back
of the head when I'm not looking
so don't have to worry about losing my
gear and so it's so random
no not random so I'm talking like my own
teammates oh so you know them and
they'll still shoot you yeah that's
fantastic
alright good friends that's good that's
good and and as you guys know it's me
Sal doe I'm here hanging out doing doing
the thing seem same stuff different day
but so uh what we're all here for is to
hear about Bob and what you know what
he's doing and Bob why don't you tell us
you know why you became a content
creator well thanks I kind of got into
it sort of backwards I've only really
been involved in Games coverage proper
for about a year and a half now in
gaming as long as I can remember but
I've been working for a few different
newspapers over the years
and a couple of years ago we were having
a conversation and we're just tie think
destiny - had just dropped I take it
some time off that week - to take a
little game keishon and some of us at
work we're talking and I was telling
them all about the game and what I was
enjoying about it and they could tell I
was really digging it and you know we
got to thinking that maybe you know
there might be a place in the arts
section for some games coverage I
thought that was a great idea and
pitched it and it didn't really go
anywhere but you know let a couple of
months go by and just you know kept
reminded I'm hey have you given this any
thought any consideration and finally
you know I wrote him a sample column and
you know they liked it enough to give it
some space and been running it a couple
of times a month and that led to the
opportunity to do attend packs last year
PAX East last year covering it for work
with the press credentials which are
just a real privilege to be able to to
do that and and so that's been going
well and recently we've make some
changes on the at the paper as far as
the column goes so we're pivoting to a
more review centric sort of thing now
instead of more of opinion pieces and
things like that and we're concentrating
now on smaller indie games you know the
triple A's you know you know by the time
we get around to covering them they're
old news people have moved on and like
you know I mean it's just you know I
mean it's still a growing sort of column
it's it's um you know it's it's sort of
building its base but like you know Call
of Duty doesn't need our help right yeah
you know so and I I'm finding right now
the smaller like indie stuff is just a
lot more interesting
these devs are making you know way more
like
no like intimate things they can afford
to take more chances they can do things
that are just really weird and might
only appeal to a smaller niche market
and I mean I love my triple a's as much
as anybody but I think a lot of them of
the interesting stuff going on right now
is definitely on the in the smaller game
so we're pivoting to that sort of
coverage and we're starting to
incorporate some some video into that
which honestly we should have probably
been doing all along but so starting to
learn how to do some editing and some
and some small-scale video production
and that's really fun and that's really
satisfying so it's um it's been a great
ride and getting to and then that column
led to getting in touch with Cognito and
the opportunity to start working with
the website and everybody there and you
know led to the opportunity to go to pax
again this year so it's been great it's
been really really rewarding yeah sure
so you you you said originally the the
location you you work for they ended up
they they didn't have a view game
section but it kind of it's starting to
evolve into that now is that because
like you have a passion for games or is
it because like that's just something
that like you kind of like enjoy and you
thought hey this would be a good idea or
how did that kind of evolve it a little
a little bit of both I mean I've I've
literally been gaming over 40 years
mm-hmm
so and it's something that I've always
enjoyed you know talking about and
thinking about and you know not just
talking about particular games
themselves but about like gaming as a
community and in the paper the newspaper
I work for the Berkshire Eagle were
based in the middle of Berkshire County
in Pittsfield Massachusetts and it's a
there's a very big art community there
especially during the spring and summer
it's rectangle it is that's where the
Boston Symphony Orchestra takes their
summers there's Williamstown Theatre
Festival so the opportunity to sort of
well if we're gonna talk about games
then we should talk about them in order
to make it work with what we're already
doing talk about them as art like you
talked about you know theater or movies
or anything else so so it sounded like a
fun way to do something a little more
creative than my regular news writing
but and talk about you know this this
hobby and maybe just you know get a
chance to expose people to aspects of
gaming or now that we're doing more
talking about Indies expose them to
games they might not have otherwise
heard of or had an opportunity to hear
about now you're seeing like all the
indie developers and things that you
talk to and you feel that those indie
developers are they're more passionate
you'd say then those triple-a developers
or is it just because you know you feel
that they they have something to prove
they have something that they want to
show that's gonna be helpful yeah I
think I don't I don't think that a
developer working on you know Assassin's
Creed or something like that is any less
passionate about what they're doing then
something like in her friend which is
made by a very small team and but I
think we're I think where the difference
is I think when you're dealing with a
smaller game and I'm just talking about
smaller in size you know but a smaller
game right a smaller game a smaller team
it can afford to
take more risks in its storytelling or
its presentation perfect example there's
a game I'm playing right now called
coffee talk it's mostly reading it's you
know interacting with these
conversations it takes place in a coffee
shop where elves and werewolves and
space men hang out it's weird in the
best kind of way and I can't imagine
like a company like Activision or
Ubisoft or something like that investing
any assets or anything like that in
there because it's a game almost
deliberately that's designed to not be
for everyone so you know in a company
like Trobe doesn't have to necessarily
work I mean they would love to make all
the money but they don't necessarily
have to worry about quarterly earning
calls and you know showing stockholders
a certain amount of profit where you
know the larger companies like
Activision and EA they absolutely do so
I think it's not less passion but when
you're making something for a mass
market you have to sort of broaden its
appeal and when you're dealing with a
smaller game you can really sort of
narrow in on it's just like well not
everybody's gonna get this but the right
people will find this game and they'll
get it and that's and that's good enough
yeah for MJ and Pharrell so when you got
when you get what do you guys think when
when you're thinking more of like indie
type games like be like these indie
developers do you guys feel like they
are able to put more passion into their
games because they don't care about what
people say and they kind of like want
like their vision to kind of like you
know be shown is it like Bob why don't
you why don't you talk first and then
yeah well I think it's yeah I think it's
just more of an opportunity to put more
of yourself in a game because again you
know when you're dealing with a smaller
dev team you're dealing with you know
maybe as little as you know as little as
one person and
maybe a deaf demon like you know 15 or
20 people whereas you know again just to
pick an easy you know example I call it
dude I mean there's hundreds and
hundreds of people who work on those
games so the the sort of personality you
know just sort of gets diluted I think
through because you're just dealing with
a much larger sort of sort of space to
fill there but I think when you have
these smaller things just made by a
couple of people I think it's just an
easier fit to in whatever way you can in
whatever way works in the context of the
game sort of get more of if not your
personal feelings your own personality
or something like that in there so I
think it's just when you're dealing on
that smaller scale I think it's just a
more natural fit to do something like
that
yeah al do you feel the same way oh my
bad I thought it myself but essentially
yeah I feel the same way that you're
starting to see a lot more happening
with Indies which i think is why I like
some indie Studios or used to be any
Studios gobbled up by Xbox because
they're pushing the envelope you know
and you think that because indie studios
are pushing the envelope that's good to
be good for large well like it'll begin
the beginning you know that's how it
always goes right like it's been the
beginning and then it becomes you know
we got to pay shareholders so you have
to make whatever so so yeah you think
eventually that I need to work this way
you think that eventually that
quote-unquote selling out even though it
really isn't selling out to them do you
think that's gonna mold what they're
like what they are doing into kind of
like you know whatever they want and the
kind of diminish the integrity of those
indie games
you know I feel like there's this like
whole cycle that happens in the industry
where like you know people get bought up
and then they get tired of making the
same game so then they leave that studio
go off and create another studio start
creating new cool stuff and in all
sudden you hear about that studio
getting bought up you know and it's like
people just keep moving around type of
things so I think until we figure out a
way to stop that from happening
you know it's just gonna be the way oh
no no I mean interrupt I I look at it
like the like the indie film sort of
movement or the indie film era of the
90s you know you had these these people
making really personal really intimate
movies you know with you know very
little budget and small crews and stuff
like that and once those movie started
to get noticed by the big studios they
started to either incorporate some of
those styles or actually bring some of
those people in to the fold and like you
know guy what's-his-name the James
Mangold the guy who directed Logan I
mean he started out making indie films
you know these these smaller really
intimate sort of movies and then
eventually started working for the big
studios they made something like Logan
yeah it's a superhero movie but it's
closer to you know like an art film then
you know traditional you know big big
blockbuster superhero movie so I'm
hoping that once that shift starts to
happen that's the kind of positive
influence you're gonna see on these on
these mass-market games yeah so there's
a there's a book I read from
audiobook cuz I barely have enough time
to read a book so I listen to my books
but um you know Bruno Bruce Campbell
he was in you know the original Living
Dead producer Sam Raimi there we go well
so Sam Raimi and him they did the their
first big movie and it was like dirt
cheap and like everyone thought like you
know this is gonna be crap this is not
gonna do anything like it took
almost 14 years for them to make their
money in their movie from that original
movie so by the time that movie came out
to the time that Sam and and Bruce
started doing all their other movies and
everything they still were promoting the
other one and then eventually because of
all of the other stuff that they were
doing people started realizing more
about living was called living dead not
let me did oh my god
Evil Dead yes um they eventually show
having people learn about that and a lot
of the movie the way that they did the
cameras for instance like one of the
camera ways that they did was that 75
I'm sorry that 45 degree tilt that they
were doing left and right when they were
running through the woods and stuff like
that
that was something that was very unheard
of right by the time it's they started
turning more mainstream you can see more
in that horror genre of people that are
starting to use those things and other
things and pretty interesting and you
know I never I never thought of it that
way because like those indie developers
are kind of pushing like the triple-a
titles and absorbing those those be
right yeah that's yeah I mean I mean
that would be my hope is that you know
you're gonna see you know that sort of
gradual shift where you know games are
willing to unable to take more chances
and things like that or you know tell
these you know stories in a different
kind of way you know I don't necessarily
expect you know smaller studios and
advanced things necessarily on the
technical end although that can
certainly happen but I think the more
you know the more voices you have at
that level I think hopefully again that
you would see that sort of like bubble
up to to the mass-market studios
hopefully in really positive ways mhm
yeah yeah MJ you feel kind of similar
but that way yeah I feel so more about
the well by you yeah it'll be nice and
exciting right there but okay yeah
so yeah that's it's pretty it's pretty
interesting
thought process so what what kind of
intrigue you Bob to want to become to
become a writer and in like you know the
way that you kind of like wanted to like
you know started becoming colic you know
columnist and all that yeah I don't know
I think it was just this sort of impulse
to tell stories you know I remember when
I was you know in grade school and
things like that that's part of the
school work that I always enjoyed I was
a I was a big reader as a kid and all of
that so I think I sort of gravitated
toward that and you know journalism
always held some kind of an interest but
it wasn't anything that I necessarily
steered toward but and then Jesus
probably in my mid-20s when I had always
heard of him but I never really read any
of stuff I somebody turned me on to
Hunter Thompson and so I read like you
know Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas and
went back and written and read the early
stuff that was a lot more sort of
straightforward journalism but still had
sort of his unique voice and it was sort
of this wake up call that you know you
could you know do not that he
necessarily always did or was always the
best example but that you could actually
do reporting and you could do news
coverage and still allow yourself enough
room to be to be creative and you know
he would put in these weird asides and
and you know come up with these sort of
fantastical scenarios to sort of explain
the point of view is coming from in a
particular section so I always found
that really interesting and then and
then when I and then when I went back to
college I just realized that UMass
Amherst
had and still has this excellent
daily student newspaper and so I gave
that a shot and then the more I started
to do that the more I really enjoyed the
all of the aspects of working in a daily
newsroom and and in news reporting and
that's really sort of where we're all
that started interesting so because you
you work for another visual for like you
know a well-known newspaper you all do
this
you work for you know Lords a gaming
dotnet also in that you know thought
thought process how do you how do you
feel the the camaraderie is and the
communication is with Lords of gaming in
comparison to like you know a regular a
regular newspaper does it have that kind
of same thought process does it has
absolutely yeah oh yeah it's it's sort
of a similar workflow I mean the you
know the discord you know I you know I
have a disc or channel for for the
gaming clan I belong to but you know and
but the Lords gaming channel especially
the writers table section is just active
all the time like more so than probably
more than most of the channels I follow
and it's that same kind of you know
daily communication it's the same kind
of like you know swapping in jokes and
chop-busting and like all the other
things that go on in any kind of
team-based work environment so it's very
and the workflow is very similar you
know like I said you'll have you know
assignments come down you know people
checking with editors that are just
giving feedback writers asking for more
time because that's what writers do to
do it so yeah it's it's very very
similar it's one of the things that I
really enjoy about the opportunity to to
get to work with the with the team
because again it feels like a real
lateral move it's a very very similar
atmosphere yeah
was there any like types of things you
didn't get that you wouldn't dare you
didn't know because you know you you
came on board what about maybe six
months ago maybe um I don't know who's
that long ago but but probably fall
probably of last year we started talking
about doing some work together yeah yeah
do you feel like the we're looking for
do you think like the techniques and
things that that that Lords gaming is
using are similar to what's a regular
type of newspaper is using in the ways
of like like the backend stuff and yeah
well the well the big the big difference
is and this was a learning curve for me
and it actually still is is coming like
I came up in in a print environment like
a strictly primont and you know like the
digital end was something you sort of
had to do because it was you know just
inevitable it's like something people
expected and now it's just like that's
you know a priority in a lot of ways is
is the digital end of things and then
coming from that print discipline over
to something that's completely digital
was a real and a real positive learning
experience because you know I never had
to worry about SEO you know I didn't
have to worry about you know whether you
know the readability score or anything
like that because I can guarantee you
know a column I would write for print if
I just move that over to WordPress and
had it look at it there's no there's no
way I'd get green lights on it because
it's a completely different writing
style just down from you know like leo
paragraph lengths and and things like
that and making everything fit and work
within a whole different set of
parameters it's been a
that's been the big difference for me
and I and it's been really valuable
because that was a blind spot for me up
until this point because I just never
had to worry about it before so so for
me that's that's the real big difference
it's just that it's a it's a whole
different way of sort of presenting
information but from everything else
from you know the structure and the way
the stories are presented and all of
that it it's very very similar and you
can see it has its roots in in sort of
that that that print tradition that
newspaper tradition so I'm sorry I was
gonna say like cuz I mean I have my I
have my articles and I know I'm Jay
writes his articles and stuff like that
and like I know I'm not the best writer
in the world but every time I write an
article and those SEO numbers and I'm
just like this is ridiculous are you
kidding me like this is makes sense I'm
reading out loud I'm like yeah this
makes sense what is going on right and I
mean enjoy you you agree when you're
kind of it's kind of like you gotta be
joking right do you feel that that that
movement for online editing and articles
and newspapers do you feel that they are
because they're I hate to work this way
but it kind of like a newer wave of
things do you think it's kind of helping
mold the old way through like does it
help you write your columns differently
because that's funny
yeah that's funny um yeah I think I
think in in very specific ways I just
speaking for myself because for I've
heard as long as I've been writing
aside from technical
I'm still a terrible speller and I'm not
a real great typist either I don't know
how I keep this job sometimes but it's
but no I as long as I've been writing
professionally I've had I've had like
two consistent criticisms one my leads
tend to be too long sometimes and too I
fall back into passive voice more than I
should and and I'll keep it short
because for the folks out there who
aren't writers so like what the hell is
he talking about he's still talking is
that the working with with the WordPress
and the system it points out both of
those things so for me in a good sort of
check on myself to realize because
sometimes it's not always clear I'll go
through like the SEO it's like you know
you know this paragraph is in passive
voice I'm like what are you talking
about and I'll read them like oh yeah
you're absolutely right and it's usually
as simple as just moving you know a
couple of sentence fragments around and
it's fixed but to have that sort of
instant feedback you know it's like this
paragraph is too long and you know this
you know you should really change the
action in this sentence this way and
then knowing that and having been
reminded of that working on the digital
end it's it's been beneficial for me to
be able to bring that those disciplines
back to the print side because again
those have been - from editor after
editor those have been - consistent
things over the years that I've been
I've had to keep an eye on because those
are bad habits that I can fall back into
if I'm not careful right well at least
you know you learned you learned
something so so you you seen before
you're a gamer you hain't play games for
a really long time
is there a particular game that you are
in love with that's like your favorite
game of all time oh man
well it there's well there's there's
there's two one from like the the old
era of of gaming and then one more
modern game is a the game I couldn't get
enough of when I was a kid Maz the
original adventure for the Atari 2600 oh
that's that's the one where you had to
type in and cue exactly what you needed
them to do no no no those were great
like the text adventures man I loved
those games like the info con games and
stuff like that like I got a Commodore
64 with a disc drive just so I could
play you know Sorek and Hitchhiker's
Guide and and and all of those like
text-based adventures now this was the
cartridge for the original Atari called
adventure and the basic and there were
different levels that got more
complicated but basically you would
wander around this by today's standard
it's really simple map and there were
three castles and each Castle had its
own key and there were dragons running
around on the map and then you had to
get somewhere and it would randomize and
somewhere on the map this golden chalice
would be hidden and had to find that
bring that back to the right castle and
actually if you've seen or read the book
ready player one that I was gonna I was
gonna ask you that's the game and that
and that that's a true story that Easter
Egg is real Atari used to publish a
magazine like Nintendo did and they and
they walked you through how to find it
if you had that game but I would just
and your character was literally just a
square on the screen and that was your
avatar and you got a sword that looked
like an arrow it looked almost like an
ASCII game and the Dragons looked like
ducks and it's almost laughable by by
today's standards but I just play the
hell out of that game just over and over
again
sunjin ready play that one it's so you
you've read the book I did not realize
saw the moon read the book I know I know
I know I figured I figured that you've
read I read the book for it well on
eBook
I listened to the book yeah I listened
to the book I stirred it no joke it was
midday on a Thursday mmm and it was I
think was like a 14 15 hour book yeah I
done by Friday while I was driving home
from work I literally listen to it now
it was so good and then I watched the
movie and I was let down because the
book is so much better
oh sure because you because you're
you're a writer and you you enjoy games
I recommend you take the time and either
read it or audio book it or if you want
I'll let you borrow my god ray player 1
or whatever it is yeah
it's so worth listen I need her yeah I'm
telling you
yeah that's I've heard the same thing
like plenty of times and yeah I was the
the movie was just kind of left me flat
I'm not gonna get into it but I had some
issues with the movie in general but but
ya know I've heard nothing but good
things about the book the other game you
were talking about I know that's alright
man
and then my actually I actually wrote a
thing about it to me that the the the
perfect video game was the original
portal that game just for me just just
had it all it I'd never played anything
quite like it
it was funny it was smart it's you know
replayable you know you can it only
takes a few hours you know there's
enough challenge there it's it's funny
as hell
and you know every time you clear one of
those rooms you just feel like the
smartest person on the planet for a
couple of minutes it's just like it's
endlessly satisfying and and I just I
just had a blast with it and you know if
people are sort of on the fence or you
know don't consider themselves gamers or
just think you know they're all one type
of thing or something like that I always
try and steer them toward that it's just
like it's it it's it forces you to think
differently and for me that's but that's
a really fun part of gaming even you
know even something like Grand Theft
Auto like those to me those are a series
of puzzles you know it's just like
here's your objective here's where you
start here's the tools you
have to finish it figure it out and part
of the fun of those games is trying to
see if you can come at you know the
missions are finding a solution to those
to those problems from a different way
and portal just delivered on that you
know every few minutes it was just super
satisfying play through and you just
realize like at the game's midpoint that
all right now you're on your own it's
just like here's you know the whole
first half of the game is okay here's
we're gonna teach you everything you
need to know now it's just like now
figure it out and that's just only for
use really clever use of gameplay we
ready to get the audio book from did you
buy it
or did you watched on YouTube because I
know that sometimes people post audio
books on YouTube yeah do you like do you
actually read the book while listening
to it or do you just like listen to it
while driving listen to it while I'm
working because I need I need to have
some type of background sounds so a lot
of people play music yes I listen to
audiobooks and podcasts I have a
rotation of about 8 or 9 podcasts and I
usually end up listening to almost one
book every month and yeah yeah that's
great I wish I could do that man because
like I've tried listening to audiobooks
I have a long commute to and I just I
just wind up I don't know if it's Road
hypnosis or I just like chill out or
whatever but all of a sudden I'll just
tune back in and it'll be like two
chapters later I don't know you know
I'll be completely lost and have to go
back it's a nightmare
I usually hour
drive into the office every morning hmm
yeah it's an hour and a half an hour and
a half out yep so usually what ends up
happening is on my drive in in the
morning I'll usually listen to a podcast
and then on my way out I usually end up
listening to the book so but I usually
try to end up listening to the book
while focusing on the road only because
I just I want to get home I want to get
yeah I want to get home but I don't want
to think about the drive so that's
that's just the way I've always done it
I might be on it like that for for at
least three or four years now yeah
that's good so going back to going back
to what you were saying about yeah my
games so so what would you say that you
kind of enjoyed those puzzle type
thinking games I mean I yeah I not not
exclusively but but ya know I I realized
actually I just I just played one it's
an older game gorgoa from Annapurna
Studios that's a Illustrated based
puzzle game you manipulate these panels
around to solve the puzzles it's all in
the artwork and it's just a blast there
was a lot of fun but yeah even if it's
not necessarily a a puzzle game per se I
think any game that sort of teaches you
a different set of of mechanics
something you can figure out as you go
you know like horizon zero dawn I
absolutely love that game and that was
one game sort of an easy not sort of but
an easier version of something like
demon souls or blood-borne or something
like that where you actually can track
yourself getting better at the combat
and you know like early on in the game
you'll avoid certain things because you
just have no skill on how to tackle them
and then by the end of the game you're
actually seeking them out just for the
sport of it so anything that you can
sort of feel yourself improve
or anything that sort of makes you think
or look at things in a different way in
order to get through them I find that
you know really interesting but you know
at the same time there's plenty of times
where I'll just you know log into
destiny too and just you know run some
strikes just you know to chill out and
relax and and you know shoot some stuff
which is you know rewarding and it's in
its own way so it's a little all over
the place but yeah if I've got a if I've
got to do some thinking sometimes with a
game I really enjoy that but there's
plenty of other times where I just like
to just shut my brain off - exactly as L
said before she likes to shoot some
noobs yeah I'm usually the one getting
shot but you know same same so what
you're saying is L this is what I was
saying if you're gonna play with Bob you
want a second account
oh no I will cost you points
oh no I will drag you down yes
don't ever ever ever let me do that bad
things bad things happen
so how when you started transitioning
your writing did you do mostly right now
towards the gaming genre of things or do
you kind of start are you writing still
your normal columns s oh oh no I the the
the gaming stuff is is very much I don't
want to say extra but it's it's it's not
my it's not my main job my main job is
still court reporting so you know some
most days in the courthouse and and
keeping an eye on you know criminal
cases and motion hearings and and and
things like that the gaming stuff is
apart from that and it's twice a month
and like I said it's a little more
focused
now that were concentrating more on
reviews and the the video component I
sort of do on my own time a bit but
that's getting more streamline the more
we do that and stuff as well but yeah
it's it's a it's a part from from the
regular job but it's it's sort of yeah
it's sort of an extra it's an extra
layer on top of it but they're two
separate things
gotcha like does your family like that
they like kind of understand like that
you that you do in this extra kind of
gaming type writing stuff in addition to
like all the other stuff are they kind
of like okay and with the understanding
of what you're doing
oh yeah no it's yeah it's a it's a big
part of you know the household here you
know it's uh and it's it's part of the
the weekly routine the you know the
PlayStation is you know we're one of
those households where it's actually
sort of the entertainment hub so even if
we're not gaming on it you know we're
you know doing our streaming through
there or running Spotify through there
or something like that so just the
machine in the house is you know one of
those appliances for lack of a better
word we use all the time but now my my
you know my girlfriend has been super
supportive of this you know throughout
you know she thought it was a great idea
when they were going to give us the the
space to do a little bit of this and you
know she knows that this is a bit more
than you know just a hobby for me it's a
big part of my life and I just thought
it was a a really great that uh I get to
you know combine you know these these
two things in a way that you know
hopefully you know people can get a hold
of and and enjoy would you sit would you
say like you know more of like a passion
project for you like the game writing
yeah yeah
oh yeah absolutely yeah I don't um you
know I don't you know I don't
necessarily look at it as I mean it's
work but you know it's not a bird a
nurse or anything like that it's
something I genuinely enjoy doing and
it's nice to have that kind of outlet so
you know if I'm you know and it's given
me these opportunities to you know to go
to events like you know like pax and to
meet some of these developers and to get
access to some of these you know these
games and get to talk about them and
things like that because it's not you
know I I didn't always have that outlet
so this is sort of another way for me to
enjoy enjoy the Hobby and I'm just
fortunate enough that I'm have access to
this platform that I get to talk about
it with you know you know in you know
some kind of an audience yeah I thought
I wanted earlier and now I'm trying to
remember I should have wrote it down
like I know that for me I like totally
can't write like that like I don't want
to figure out what passive tints and all
that and like I don't want like I don't
like writing or I only ever did exactly
what I needed to do to get a good grade
yep but yeah yeah so more power to you
but I still can't remember my question
right now so what game is the most
anticipating for this coming year I got
it I got to see what cyberpunks about
I'm really looking really looking
forward to that specific console
um well I'd honestly one of the
disadvantages of writing for a living is
there's no money in it yeah yeah so
right now we're we're a one console
household so yeah anything I play is
gonna be on PlayStation 4 for the most
part maybe some mobile stuff but yeah
it's got to be available for me in some
format there for me to be able to work
with it at this point but yeah so it'll
be I'm going to check it out on ps4 when
it comes out but you know you know the
studio is top-notch
looks like they put a lot of work into
it the delays a drag but you know most
cases you know a game's better if it
cooks a little longer yeah exactly yeah
the perfect example man you know it's
just like you know came out and was like
what the hell is this they went back
fixed it and it made all the money last
weekend so I put a flag on the play here
and you weren't old enough with the
original Sonic came out there no I'm
talking about how they had to remake the
character yeah so you don't stream or
anything or you just write I yeah I
haven't been that's something I might
get into like I said we just started a
just started a doing doing gameplay
demos and video reviews for for the
paper now so I'd have I kicked myself
because I was between jobs at the
perfect time the ps4 would just I think
destiny one was just launching and
twitch was still just getting its feet
on the ground and and all of that and I
had
all the time in the world and just
didn't just just just didn't stick to it
or anything like that but but doing some
kind of streaming is something that's
always been interesting to me so hoping
to maybe get into that maybe sometime
this spring but left to see and but no I
think it'd be fun but yeah I kind of
kicked myself sometimes for not getting
uh not getting more into that in the
early days you were there at the time
and you were playing something that you
knew would have been like perfect to
play yeah like I wish I was ready sooner
like with all my stuff I think I waited
like forever it's finally bite the
bullet and get everything and like try
to make it happen because I knew before
most people that Microsoft was gonna be
buying bean so like I was on beam before
it turned into mixer just started and
I'm thinking to myself like if I was
playing like I could I could have been
something now but because of that it's
like ya know I like I don't know what
may come later I know that from the most
part I just do this for fun because I
enjoy it and I like having people to
talk to or are you playing and screaming
hey look at that noob basically yeah I
saw absol I watched you play apex all
time do I do not have that ability to do
that anymore I know I have to be like I
have to look so funny so I know
sometimes I look over and on my damn my
face is focused and that's how I was
when I used to do titanfall because it's
the same type of
game what no he already asked what game
are you looking most forward to what are
you playing now and do you play with
your children no I don't have don't have
kids of my own we have a we have a
granddaughter three year old so she's
yeah we try to keep the games off when
when she's around but I've playing
actually I got back into Borderlands 3
so I've been playing that a bit I picked
up like everyone else had picked up
Division 2 on the cheap last weekend it
was down in like 3 bucks so I picked
that up so I started playing through
that I'm enjoying that and then for
review I'm playing coffee talk this
little weird indeed conversation yeah
yeah I saw that I'm actually yeah yeah I
saw that I'm gonna of the things I'm
hoping to drop in on because it's a it's
a weird game man but I'm kind of I'm
kind of fascinated by it so looking
forward to talking behind it I think
it's haven't played anything quite like
it it's it's one of those things it's
definitely not for everybody but it's
what I'm also thinking a lot about it
when I'm not playing it so well talking
we'll talk after the podcast because I
think there's some information that we
have to discuss because I don't know if
you're on the emails that I'm on so okay
but yeah that's awesome it's awesome
what's doing is there anything else I'm
gonna ask you your final question if l
has any more questions she can just just
yell if there's any if you can live
in one video game fantasy environment
what would it be so like you'd like to
live on the shire would you love to live
on course and would you left you know in
a video game world is there anything
that you can think of wow that's a great
question man it doesn't have to be
fantasy world - yeah yeah yeah oh jeez
because most of the stuff I watch it you
know every all those you know all those
worlds are kind of effed up in their own
special way and I'm like I don't know
you know I think you know it yeah cuz
because nothing will be permanent I I
think that uh I think I think probably
the most interesting like environment I
can think of right off the time I had to
be in would be the city in breath effed
Auto three that nameless city there
because that was like the first time I
can remember at least in the modern era
where the game is just all about just
just breaking the rules you know like
like you know there was there were no
Lynn if you could if you could if you
could if it gave you something to do and
you could think if you can think of it
you could do it and you know you'd be
playing that game and you'd be like oh
they're not gonna let me do this and
they do the game does and there were all
sorts of really interesting in weird
ways you know to break the game it was I
think the last probably the only Grand
Theft Auto game that I played enough to
actually and it was a small enough map
or I could actually like sort of have
the map memorized I knew where to get to
particular buildings and stuff like that
and again that's one of those games that
just sort of alters your the way you you
think about playing games it's just like
it's kind of linear but there's all
these other ways to to enter
act with it and I think it really sort
of expanded at least for me it sort of
expanded my my thinking of games just
like it encouraged you to color outside
of the lines so I think I think that
would be a really interesting
environment to hang out in in for a
while and and you know and you get a
rocket launcher solution every problem
is just like traffic jam rocket launch
rocket launcher exactly straight
somebody slow in the line in front of
you rocket launch L you're good yeah I
think so okay sounds good so Bob you
tell everyone where they can find you
you know oh yeah happy to do so you can
find most of my work at Berkshire Eagle
dot-com and my gaming writing appears on
that website in the landscape section
the arts section and best way to find me
online is on twitter at at
done four one three and and and you can
also find some of my writing i'm sorry
on the lord's gaming dotnet as well
there you go thank you
and thank you very much for for coming
and thanks for having me man it's been a
pleasure it's great thank you very much
all right MJ and Twitter
baby MJ you can find me on snapchat
let's say beep 101 and then twitch MJ is
a boss and then you can check out my
articles on the wards a gaming dotnet
boom there you go
that's what's poppin yeah find me on
Twitter at l-boogie o 208 and our mixer
at LBL 208 and then on Saturday mornings
on YouTube growing the gaming the
podcast at 12:00 p.m. Eastern 9 a.m.
Pacific and
I'm starting to remember well that's
pretty sad I'm here for you really I
appreciate it and you know me it is me
now though SN al why do you can find me
on Twitch Monday to Friday other than
when I'm here from 7:00 to 10:00
I have articles on the Lords of gaming
dotnet I have a Twitter which I'm pretty
active on I'm on discord in the Lords of
gaming discord pretty active there you
know you can always contact me wherever
which way and you know you can do that
and da let's say thank you again to Bob
for coming today I greatly appreciate
you for you know taking the time out and
you know if you have any questions for
any guests or anybody please email us at
roundtable stream team at gmail.com
we're gonna be putting up our article
there's on eye alerts podcasts YouTube
page for you guys very shortly you'll
get everything on a Twitter and on
Twitter on iTunes Spotify and things
like that come Wednesday and remember
Lords of gaming is on Wednesdays at 1:00
and check out us out Lords of games net
for all the gaming news that you could
possibly think of and we are on table
stream that's when I usually post
information about who's gonna be on the
stream and what's going on and all that
fun stuff so that is all over there and
remember everybody to dream big and keep
gaming and we will see you all next week
thanks everybody have a good one